allora adesso vi spiego
e successo che volevamo registrare un
video io e sasha e poi è uscito fuori
questa roba delle skyworks che io avevo
già fatto tempo fa
e vabbè siccome abbiamo fatto delle
partite della madonna
ho deciso di mettere questo video in cui
gioco ha mai si è strano che io giochi a
questa roba
però merita la vita cioè vi giuro su dio
che merita la vita quindi vi lascio al
primo dei due episodi che vedrete
e vabbè buona visione
allora solo i famigli tre club mette lo
faccio col cazzo sul tavolo di questa
parte la meta arriva rivalenti lingue il
team 22
ci siamo nome si sono messe due non ci
sono grande adesso siamo in gruppo
possiamo fare le cose ora sarebbe mondo
proprio due persone che non fanno
assolutamente nulla siamo con due
sconosciuti bene e lama metodi non cerco
di sconosciuti quindi slogan partiti
gemello siamo tutti capitan sparrow
morto e invece no rubiamo tutto questo
dobbiamo fare chi è che devo picchiare
picchio la gente io so risiamo
sull'olandese volante sulla perla nera
questa la perla nera ciao bella batte il
pugno immaginario ben rye abbiate preso
tutto dalle candele cafè si segnò il
capitano ragazze non prendete delle
frecce una spada acqua moriamo tutti e
io ho preso una spada di legno sono
forte araya qualcuna delle frecce all
arco
io una canna da pesca se vuoi io ho una
spada di legno e volete o anche le erano
di chiamare una bolletta da pagare ma
cozza e all arco ma non le frecce e io
ho un altro arco se vuoi faccio io archi
e rompula non pro pilar che lo tiri o
dio c'è uno tutto tutto fluorescente
laggiù ma raga m'avete cibo io ho una
torta o anche del rum wired viene dai
è una botola di roma come aspetta
aspetta guarda guarda un blocco un
blocco ok quando avrà grazie grazie sul
rito braga mancano tredici giocatori e 6
sono nostri l'effetto stiamo vincendo
quanto ce la meritiamo il centro laica
non sto capendo ma io devo andare avanti
io potete farlo voi costruisci il tuo
lorenzo e vabbè non ho più blocchi
ragazzi era più facile costruire la
salerno reggio calabria ragazza sul
ponte malato dove è vero la spara spara
uomo bravo cosmico un pippone
io posso pescare la gente comune se ne
fa di tutto chi è quello provato a
saltare ma si è chiesto ma tu sei tutto
droga a quello si drogano e guardarlo da
rara ci ha fatti ce la fate mai buttati
lì ma sei scemo play logistica il
suicidio e voi ho seguite ad essere
ammazzata su di col fuoco roma vado
anch'io eh io sono forte e va fra il
collo a betty proteggono re ma il patto
è forte
uno è morto e mancano ma da camera
manca solo lui non muore nota solo
l'amore due case da un'ottima pcm ma
cosa vuoi da me ma dal fronte alla mano
a iaia perché c'è con me che cazzo vuoi
ma darò ma sono giunte vitaccia e non lo
so mi ha veramente ucciso maragna quanto
laga o mezzo come ucciso
fate fate essere invincibile era
invincibile prende fuoco fame dai
sitting contro un raga ma scappati ma
ammazzatelo è semplice ma quello sì
mangiare mele d'oro a ecco perché vince
la casta allagando tutto maggio regala
sembra di vedere due vecchi che scopano
ma quanto lo state menaldo non muore mai
male italia e rocky balboa fame anche
dei poveri
e vabbè sta mangiando nel pollo veloci
prima che ci che nei nuggets faccio un
effetto ma avete della lava per
buttargli addosso
adesso adesso questo volevo ma edizione
bulls e a caio in faccia ha usato
l'acqua dai spacca adesso campo capitola
censi stazionava da oggi non ci sono più
cibo e non a pc sta mangiando a un'ora e
mezza dalla città di [ __ ] e al buffet
suo uomo
basta devi morire figlio di satana
puntano a butta giù tutta la lava adesso
adesso resto ecco quanto sei bravo h1
manca qualcuno leggendo e dove è nata è
sempre lui che non è morto si è
aggrappato da qualche parte di una barca
verde e la barca a vela e nikos è vero
eccolo il 5 del cibo voleri aver vinto è
morto è caduto ed efficiente ed
efficiente
ravi caso è crashato server è una
partita talmente di merda che ha
cresciuto tutto il server memorabile
memora bellissimo siete stati bravissimi
complimenti solid snake vieni qua sono
qua dobbiamo ingrossarsi tutti
vieni vieni filo la bussola super la noè
grazie se non reggo bello
andiamo nella savana tavana e quale
saranno a tutto quanto quella che sua
mamma e pure questa dai haga che nessuno
fa il cazzo di pomaio lo facciamo playa
noi a chi vuol dire pry open operaio la
conosce la canzone di un opa su
huffington
ma come mai ma come ci dirà gt che la
canta vedono fago affitto e non faccio
privacy quando a nostro figlio di remo
io ascoltavo gucci boy è lì che scenderà
lacrima ieri figlio ti devo raccontare
una storia di operai mentre mangi la
pasta
mio nonno faceva priory lo prendono per
il culo tre secondi all'espulsione
chicago legge non cade accade prefetto
soleva fare meglio ma stamapa i bookie
la gruviera bella gara ci sono le ceste
nascoste tipo e specie se la cercano
trovata un'auto nata una è questo c'è un
acqua in cima alla libertà nascosta
bella non è una cesta sono scemo
ecco ecco c'è una sul tetto qua
sull'albero praga io sono fatto una
certa un botto di roba se volete venire
qui arriva arrivare io ho trovato delle
torte volete nelle torte e non di qua
dall'altra parte dove mi stai andando a
scusa poi è nato quanta roba c'è qua
dentro
parah parah ha insegnato gli shaolin a
prendere a pugni
raga io ho del rum volete distribuisco
tn st tieni del vino in a1 ci sono
annate le no per far largo io ho una
freccia sola dove però le uova le uova
luogo ragaglia un sacchetto di farina
come lo interessato te e io le uova
faccia morosità siamo a posto ma che lo
paura tranquilli ragazzi tranquilli noi
siamo un team esperto in queste cose
riusciamo a fare cose tutte queste cose
chi lo lanciano giu brava session sei un
killer ma poi c'è qualcosa può dentro ci
sono liste dove dove dove madonna quanta
roba mai mai rai fra casa treni tutta
prendi siamo né voglio fare in
velocistiche kiss kiss ragazzi l'unica
roba che non una spada manca solo la
cosa abbia portato vedrai una grazie
amore chi vogliamo però se posso
mangiare le uova crude sud a nord mode
uova crude sulla gente ma in gra finito
malissimo la cava chi è ancora vivo non
capisco è stato farcito come una
porchetta sono tutti vivi noi degli
altri perché non vedo nessuno non c'è
nessuno e vabbè ti lamenti con noi
posso picchiare voi voglio picchiare
qualcuno io però scusami ma noi siamo
arrivati da dove da qua da casa nostra
perché qua c'è un ponte abbastanza
costruito cioè youtuber a casa loro
che schifo merde a malavedo c'è gente la
giusta ed a riproporlo giuda qua anche
se non posso buttarlo giù impossibile ma
guarda è un tiro al bersaglio ma
bruttissimo aspettare ci sono laggiù
baradei sono in cima per qualcuno ma non
c'è nessuno proprio loreti sento assente
come than the semi carro tomba di dante
è anche quello dove che sei cominci male
si è trovati lassini
rimasti solamente sei team vabbè allora
niente aspettiamo qualche la gente
capisca che deve morire ragazzi su
questa china briscoe lina vesco lina con
ha portato le carte per aspettare e dai
alla rai ma facciamo facciamo quelli che
hanno il cazzo duro più degli altri
andiamoli a scoppiare problema è che ci
sono tanti team così impositivo che le
brigate rosse possono accompagnare solo
guardatelo mairago guardatelo male
mattarella che puoi venire suicida da
solo comunque perché la sua base sta
dando piena di lava morali non lo so è
una ottica ha dato fuoco all albero
inforcato ramacca se non sia imbeccando
io vado dall'altra parte 1 dopo che tra
una parte una dall'altra
nel frattempo mangion pesce
mi piace il pesce riposo e su gusti non
ti stiamo giudicando socio va beh
potremmo tornare nella nostra isola
c'è uno che abbiamo uscendo fuori da lo
vedi beckham anni ma è vero ragazzi
riferme ecco nascondetevi con questo
nascondete dilaga questo critiche dove
sono io ci credo no non è vero ma accade
è caduto sulla forte sarà forte lì che
avesse mai kraft player drums tips
grazie amici sono rimasti 1111 henraux
gaming hesl ma la vera domanda come ha
fatto rimanere 111 gli altri del gruppo
da cazzo sta suicidando non hanno
proprio voluto partecipare guardandola
nelle prosime oppure stanno giocando
così che beh non risultò prima fra che
non vi vedo mai nella vita ma te dovrei
che sposino dove ti sei taggato tutti
brutto una cosa o anche una bottiglia
raga ubriachiamo gli u19 aspetti che si
sboccia i drogati se mi chiacchio che
quanto eco attento ai coscia li sto
sparando alla tua sto sparando a lato
c'è una squadra speciale cobra 11 che
giocare con voi siriano in tempo anche
se comunque è parente di quello che
ucciso prima attenzione gli oli lo
uccido di nuovo anche lui gli lancio un
uovo l'ho preso l'ho preso amazon o
dovuta madre
ma non ha più frecce cazzo e neanche la
sfiga lancia una mela o c'è uno che sta
arrivando dall'alto bastardo dotato st
io non lo posso prendere non le frecce
se adesso mi ha visto che sta
indietreggiando dalla parte dove eccolo
lo vedo e lanciato un nuovo una cosa
bravo pescara quindi ragazzi che un
connubio episodio per adesso perché in
realtà la parte ancora più bella
viene dopo perché non hai idea di che
cosa è successo però non mi viene una
roba lunghissima quindi ve lo spezzato
in due parti
spero vi sia piaciuto ringrazio sasha
ringrazio surreal power pietro che era
ragazzo che bello che ha partecipato a
questo video la cicala all'investitore
quindi ragazzi proprio video vi sia
piaciuto consente vita piace momento mi
piace che sto facendo
lasciando momento mi piace anche a
pagine di facebook e come tiziana da
reti di semplici vediamolo prossimo
video verrà ragazzi